vous l'avez entendu ces étudiants
manifestaient notamment contre les
propositions développées dans le rapport
laurent sur la rénovation des
universités un rapport qui devait être
présenté officiellement aujourd'hui par
françois fillon le ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur mais
apparemment ce rapport risque fort de
tomber aux oubliettes de l'histoire
françois fillon interrogé par son parti
merlin tout le monde reconnaît en privé
dans la communauté universitaire qu'il
faut faire évoluer les structures de
l'université
on a aujourd'hui l'occasion de dire à
l'occasion d'une élection présidentielle
comment elles doivent évoluer
c'est un rapport qui n'engage pas le
gouvernement qui est destiné à ouvrir un
débat qu'on le lise et qu'on le critique
est ce que ça ne veut pas dire que vous
prenez certaine distance par rapport à
ce rapport laurent mais bien sûr puisque
si j'avais voulu proposer une politique
de réformes universitaires qui soit
celle du gouvernement j'aurais pas
demander à monsieur laurent de la sphère
de le faire à ma place j'aurais fait des
propositions le gouvernement n'a jamais
dit qu'il allait augmenter les droits
d'inscription il a confié à monsieur
laurent et à des hommes et des femmes de
gauche comme de droite
le soin de faire des propositions sur
l'avenir de l'université
si la communauté universitaire est
unanime contre l'augmentation des droits
des étudiants et meilleur des droits
d'inscription et bien il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation des droits d'inscription
je remarque que les présidents
d'université eux réclament aussi cette
augmentation des droits d'inscription au
moins pour les étudiants qui ont des
moyens financiers qui leur permettent de
le faire alors la question est posée
ouvrons le débat en refusant de débattre
et en caricaturant le rapport laurent
les organisations qui le font ne rendent
pas service à l'université parce que il
prône en réalité d'immobilisme
le tribunal correctionnel